is the ultimate goal to eventually be a
president is that kind of what you're
solving for where there is because you
said something very very important at
the beginning you said i treat this like
a startup and it's a 10-year plan right
okay that changes perspectives which
means
if you're going for 10 years the world
kind of just watched you play and that
was kind of like uh you know whatever
you want to call it all-star game people
are like okay this guy can actually play
good for him he's got the talent to be
on the stage seven debates nobody's
gonna be on seven debates and you were
blobbing on being seven debates and they
kind of didn't want you to be on there
so you weren't afraid to go up against
them and you were talking [ __ ] which was
great
and then you were also proposing hey
this short to format debate two-minute
answers is not necessary we need
something a little bit more long-form so
i can really explain what i'm doing and
all this stuff which people started
listening to maybe this guy's got a
point maybe this guy's got a point but
are you now saying okay i went for this
people noticed you know what this guy
can hang maybe next i go for you know
mayor senator governor congress and then
eventually in 10 years i'm going to go
be a president what is that vision or
the next five moves with you yeah
my vision is to try and get this country
through a really difficult time because
if you fast forward not even that long i
mean we all saw what happened on january
6th uh last year
uh unfortunately i don't think that's a
one-time event i think that you're
you're going to see us slipping towards
more consistent
uh
unrest and political strife and violence
um and so when you ask what my plan is
my plan is to do everything i can to to
keep us functional and shore it up to
your
enthusiasm about a unity ticket i would
be super pumped about a unity ticket uh
now i'm going to convey to you all like
are people actually talking about a
unity ticket behind the scenes yes they
are you know like am i going to do
everything i can to help usher that into
being yes i will so
i'm about trying to solve problems even
now
i will say like i don't really care that
much
if i die
x years from now never having been
present united states i mean that was
true even when i was running for
president united states you know i
didn't go home and you know be like
bemoaned to my
you know i'm like the child of
immigrants who's trying to do right by
my country
uh and it's just not doing very well
uh you know what that kind of reminds me
of a slight like uh when they asked
chris paul or westbrook so let me ask
you a question if you retire playing nba
and you never make the win the
championship you okay with that yeah
because i go to a beautiful family i
make 18 million dollars you're xyz it's
okay if i make it or not and then
they're fans get so furious how could
you say that yeah i want somebody to
want to win the championship andrew you
got to tell me if i ever win i would be
you know that whole scene with the
uh trump and oprah where uh oprah says
do you have any plans of ever running
for office you've seen this before a
million times and not a million times
but you know it's all over the place and
he says i don't know bro but if i ever
did i would win because i'm a winner
right the idea is people want to get
behind somebody that's saying hey if you
vote for me i'll be able to do xyz so
for you
if we go 10 years from now let's fast
forward ideal place where you think you
can contribute the most
is it more in a free market i'm gonna go
be a media personality do that like you
did at cnn is it gonna be more behind
the scenes
leading a third party and helping
somebody become president or no front
runner i'm gonna be the talent and the
voice and getting in there getting dirty
to help make some real changes in this
country and to do that you kind of need
to fight to get at the highest level of
office if you're gonna make some real
change
where would that be what's the most
likelihood of seeing andrew in which of
these situations
i don't think our current structures are
going to solve our problems in the time
that we have and so i'm laser focused on
trying to make it so that they could one
of my great fears so there's a period
you know running for president uh you
know thousands of people coming out to
see me and support me and like you feel
like wow people are really investing
their hopes for the future in me
and one of my concerns was to your point
patrick that you get in there and you
can't actually deliver for them why
because the system is not set up to
allow you to actually solve their
problems either because the politics
aren't there at the party mechanics or
our government itself
and so that's what we have to try and
resolve
uh quickly because
the problems aren't going away in my
opinion the problems are actually
speeding up somewhat um so of those
things you named i think it's going to
be around this uh third party movement
democracy reform right now as we're
having this conversation 62 percent of
americans want to move on from the
duopoly and if you go back to the
business
metaphor if you showed up at a
marketplace and there were two providers
and 62 percent of people wanted a choice
you would start a third provider
immediately maybe a fourth one a fifth
one too um now in this marketplace the
two
companies have said no no no like you
can't have a third choice uh you know
we're gonna keep you from being on the
ballot we're gonna ignore you in the
media we're gonna like have um you know
we're gonna sue you like whatever the
heck heck it is um but the mckay the the
truth of it is that 62 percent of people
want a choice and i'm saying like well
let's get you that choice then because
if you get that choice it's going to be
good for the country so is it is it a
problem with the current duopoly
the two-party system or the current
iteration of the two-party system
because we have other parties with the
libertarian party the green party etc
etc but you're watching a sort of
reformation within the parties
themselves post-trump is it is it the
two-party system or the current
iteration of it
uh the the current iteration of it's the
worst version of it and unfortunately
it's going to get worse um so
uh if you were to rewind
50 years or so the two parties were
actually somewhat indistinguishable
you know like it wasn't as dramatic
there wasn't this left right thing it
was like you know like democrat
republican were kind of
uh different
flavors of uh of you know
vanilla
it would be like you know french vanilla
versus just plain manila um that changed
over the last number of years where you
ended up with um with it getting
combined with you know different factors
whether it's urban rural whether it's
racial whether you know um it's economic
um and so this version of the two-party
system is
possibly the worst um but i say that
believing that it's going to get worse
still
so
um so you have you know this this
version is our founding father's
nightmare come to life if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]